ils n'ont pas attendu longtemps avant de
réagir
tant que toutes les forces étrangères
n'auront pas complété le retrait de
notre pays nous ne participerons à
aucune conférence censée prendre des
décisions sur l'afghanistan les talibans
renoncent donc à participer aux
pourparlers de paix avec le gouvernement
de kaboul du 24 avril au 4 mai prochain
à istanbul en turquie
quelques heures auparavant le
gouvernement de joe biden avait annoncé
que toutes les troupes américaines
quitteraient l'afghanistan sans
condition d'ici le 11 septembre un
départ coordonnée et simultanée avec
celui des autres forces de l'otan nous
allons entamer un retrait ordonné des
forces restantes avant le 1er mai et
prévoyons d'avoir sorti toutes les
troupes américaines du pays avant le 20e
anniversaire du 11 septembre
nous avons dit aux talibans sans la
moindre ambiguïté que nous répondrons
avec force à toute attaque contre les
soldats américains pendant que nous
procédons un retrait ordonné sur un
repos de quatre mois par rapport à la
date conclut dans l'accord historique
signé avec les talibans par son
prédécesseur donald trump en février
2020 à doha au qatar un corps devant
permettre le retrait plus tard au 1er
mai prochain des troupes américaines à
condition que les insurgés empêchent à
tout groupe terroriste opéré depuis les
territoires afin qu'ils contrôlent mais
aussi qu'ils entament des négociations
de paix avec le gouvernement de kaboul
des négociations depuis dans la passe et
qui devait être relancée par la
conférence d'istanbul
un départ qui selon washington pourrait
avoir des conséquences dans une lettre
au président afghan ashraf ghani
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken a d'ailleurs prévenu qu'un
retrait américain pourrait entraîner des
gains territoriaux rapide de la part des
talibans